one of the most unbelievable memories i
have of your career i was watching you
at the democratic national convention it
was a crazy time and i remember you just
being on the convention floor and
cronkite i think threw to you and
suddenly you're in a fist fight well
1968 democratic convention it was a
crazy time crazy place what was
happening is that they wanted total
complete control over the convention
inside outside they were having a hell
of a time trying to keep control it was
insane rioting in the streets and that
sort of thing but inside they were
determined to keep control so the
situation very briefly was a delegate
was being escorted he was being hustled
out of the hall
by
people who were dressed in civilian
clothes not policemen right so i'm a
floor reporter i see a delegate guys
have him by the armor trying to hustle
him out he got a big delegate badge this
is the story so i attempted to put the
microphone and saying sir what's going
on here security people block it aside i
tried naturally position myself in front
so they have to run over me to get to me
the security guy hit me in the solar
plexus practically knocked me out wow
not me to the floor because they wanted
to get him off the floor because as soon
as they get outside that floor perimeter
i as a correspondent can't go past that
perimeter so the idea was to get him
outside the perimeter so let me ask you
something do you realize in that moment
oh my god i've got great television
going on here nope you don't didn't it
on my head didn't in my head were you
afraid you could get killed
no i wasn't afraid to get killed i i'd
already absorbed a pretty
pretty tough punch but here's what
happens howard if you're any good as a
reporter
nothing matters but the story you get so
laser beam focused it's what tennis
players call zoned on the story you're
not thinking about television
you're only thinking about the story now
in the minutes certainly the hours
afterward you say
wow they got that on live television
can't believe it do people start calling
you up and congratulating you at cbs
news are they like wow man you just did
it you just made great television no i
don't nobody nobody said any such thing
everyone was kind of stunned
uh but afterwards when you analyze it do
you sit there and go you know what these
sons of [ __ ] are going to notice me
now i'm in line to get this anchor job
no i don't think about that then really
i can say truthfully i did not think
about i didn't think about the anchor
job until
late in the 1970s but here's the
question i want to make sure i ask you
before this is all over so when you're
in afghanistan and you're risking your
life and you're in vietnam and you're
risking your life but then you compare
it to the stories you covered in cu in
this country like the civil rights
movement where you go down south you're
covering martin luther king and the
whole movement
some hillbilly clans guy sticks a gun to
your head right you've had that happen
you've had a gun to your head and they
try to threaten you right what did the
guy say to you when he put a gun to your
head well the quote was um
i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
with a gun to your head
you had to be scared
you bet so was it in a sense more
dangerous working in this country or
working overseas
and i think the answer is this country
right
well certainly as dangerous that
situation mind you fortunately for me
the light man had his own gun if you
remember he then he put the gun to the
to the gun wielders
jesus yeah uh but that's look there's no
denying it that was that was dangerous
did you think he was going to shoot you
i thought he might
do does your whole life start to go in
front of do you start to think about the
kids and your wife and you start to go
man i i probably always going to be the
anchorman one day
well that's true your life goes whether
it's afghanistan or deep south all of a
sudden it's flashing in front of you
wife
kids life what might be
see in my eyes that's why you were a
successful anchorman you had lived all
those experiences i don't think guys
today
a lot of anchor guys are specifically
trained as actors
to read the news
they've never really covered a story
they've never risked their lives true
that's true in many cases not always
their fault and not only do i think they
miss something uh as performers as
people who can get the ratings of
demographics
but they're missing a lot of adventure
in their life i mean i won't get you
i've lived the journalism of joy i i
love doing i have a passion doing it but
howard this you've hit on something very
important that i think the audience
recognizes
if you burn with a hot hard flame for
news and news is what your life is about
not the makeup not the lights not being
in the studio not being what i call a
hot house plant
the audience will recognize it but the
people who hire anchor people don't
believe that